vous voyez là encore assez claire marie
pour broder rouge
je bois mais quand je fais quelques
heures comme ça je ça diminue il y a
quand même des dessins qui doivent être
plus difficile que les autres ont avoué
un honneur qui sont beaucoup plus chargé
la queue louis jouvet et la coiffe ici
par exemple beaucoup plus difficile pour
vivre les lacets c'est plus espacés dont
5000 da silva ici c'est beaucoup plus
serré comme vous même vous faites vos
dessins vous essayez de les faire qui
peuvent convenir à votre au travail que
oui mais on peut pas toujours non plus
parce que la forme de la coiffe et exige
que toi aussi oui oui oui les fleurs
bien sûr permettre n'importe quelle
fleur il faut que ça convient puisqu'il
ya la largeur il ya aussi la hauteur
linge je n'ai jamais vu ce dessin là se
joue même s'il avait c'est un nouveau
dessin oui vous avez fait rire
alors là il est presque finie suis là et
je vais le découper non seulement broue
haïti s'est également mais il faut
découper et le tissu de sous ça c'est de
leur camp dit il ya plus tu veux non me
tue le depuis presque depuis la guerre
on n'en fait plus beaucoup
vous avez brodé sur tulle aussi bien
l'avouer au début oui j'ai appelé mon
métier j'ai fait surtout oui au début
quand je suis allé à prendre je n'ai pas
fait des coiffes j'ai fait des pochettes
et en sus des pochettes oui oui et puis
on faisait aussi des empiècements de
chemise que ses avants
après quand je fais des coiffes quand
j'ai fini d'apprendre je fais les
coiffes qui appuient comme ça et je
travaillais pour madame dornic la wii ou
avez vous appris votre métier mari j'ai
appris mon métier ou pas loin de chez
moi minéraux j'ai eu une demoiselle bn
quel âge aviez-vous mari j'avais pas
tout à fait 14 ans que j'ai quitté
l'école en juillet tant vos vacances et
je vais 14 ans 9 ans qui a dit appeler
you on faisait des coiffes quand on est
presque fini de son métier combien de
temps reste et vous un avant tout ça je
fais 18 mois 18 - oui et après ça vous a
travaillé chez vous après j'ai fait un
peu chez moi
oui et j'ai fait aussi comme les autres
on faisait juste l'hiver et on faisait
la saison aussi l usine l usine on
travaillait plus pour les avoués iv
c'était des meilleurs rapports
certainement que de broder une histoire
pareille un oui mais après alors
libérant recevez la broderie
oui vous avez donc la coiffe de vent oui
le talent et et les lacets là c'est le
dal et combien de temps marie
mettez-vous pour faire tout cela pour
faire là quoi fumer à peu près trois
semaines sans trop travailler oui il
faut bien et je suis en train de finir
une paire de lacets pour la coiffe que
j'ai fait ici je voulais finir le
mariage de votre petit fils les primes
avec mariage de ma fille tu fumes 1
non
on
sept corps doit être parmi les plus
anciennes du pays bigouden
elle remonterait vers 1840 elle a cette
particularité c'est d'avoir le bigouden
ces petites pointes et qui est très
marquante dans celle ci puisqu'elle
représente presque le quart de la coiffe
il vient tout même un motif
traditionnels que je retrouve
c'est la chaîne de vie qui d'après les
vieux brodeur était un symbole de
peering
ici j'ai une autre quoi mais qui est
monté tels qu'on les montées en fin du
siècle dernier et actuellement il ya le
talent eden et la coiffe dessus
elle possède aussi sa tycoon et des
motifs traditionnels qui sont suivis
dans les coins demi deuil qui est la
coiffe de toiles brodées blanc avec le
soleil les plumes de paon et aldo adapté
vers 1885
puis nous arrivons à la fin du siècle
c'est le début des coiffes brodé sur or
grandi ou linkedin
avec encore des motifs traditionnels qui
sont elles le soleil les plumes de paon
et les fougères symbole de la famille
nombreuse
mais cette famille nombreuse ne pouvait
pas rester tout dans le même foyer
il fallait qu'un se dispersent et chaque
fois que l'on voit la fougère dans les
motifs des broderies bigoudène que ce
soit dans les gilets brodés ou dans les
coiffes elle est séparée par un petit
une petite étoile et ceux qui arrivent à
dire dans chaque famille chacun s'en va
suivant son étoile
suivant son plein
tous
ici la coiffe grandi et avec quelques
jours celle ci remonte vers 1910 et
toujours les motifs traditionnels
seulement elle grandit on retrouve à
l'heure des motifs plus fantaisie on
sent que les bigoudènes ont voyagé et
qu'elles ont vu d'autres motifs de
broderie que les motifs traditionnels
ici il ya deux poids de cérémonie toute
brodée également sur pullulent dans
cette fois ci et la coiffe continue à
grandir et à s'enrichir
voici l'une des dernières brodé sur thur
d'attraits vers 1940 à peu près à ce
qu'après la guerre on a pu retrouver de
thunes et on a dû comme on continue à le
faire pour les coiffes actuellement les
brodé sur organdi
ici une coiffe du pays bigouden qui a
son originalité qui n'est pas tout à
fait dans la tradition car elle et ses
deux petits motifs de fleurs mais je
crois qu'elle est unique
ici une coiffe de deuil et c'est assez
curieux
vela la bigoudène dans le grand deuil
portaient des coiffes en toile jaune
je crois que c'est assez spécial haut
pays bigouden on n'a jamais vu de
coiffes de couleur dans les autres
coiffes bretonnes
ça s'appelait le coin 2001
ceci est très différente avec l'un des
motifs traditionnels mais c'est assez
rare de retrouver ce grand soleil dans
les
nous
bon
mon
c'est moi qui réponds ce n'est quoi vous
êtes de repasseuse de coiffes
non je ne suis pas raciste ou quoi que
je fais et s'il puisque vous voyez j'ai
retenté quoi ce sont mes deux meetings
ont alors commencé des choses brison tél
au départ la coiffe n'est pas ronde au
départ la coiffe des parents et les
plates et les plats vous voyez est alors
que fait-on avant de de passer le faire
sous la coiffe je crois que l'avis donné
oui que peut vous montrer comment jamie
donne la croise y at-il dans dans
l'amidon de l'amidon de l'eau oui c'est
tout vous ne jouez pas autre chose la
bougie je n'ai pour faire un la coiffe
un briller un peu ont servi oui mais au
fond ce patrick et c'est pas pour la
douce douce durcir non et après on fait
le ménage
le mélange avec de l'amidon cuit on met
du cru oui et c'est ça qui fait durcir
pas quoi mais non je vais vous montrer
comment on la repasse il faut un ter
très chaud autrement ça c'est pas assez
dur il faut que la fin du passage toute
l'humilité de la vie dont disparu un oui
vous voyez elle durcit mais n'est pas
encore assez j'ai pas encore si vous
n'avez pas une autre à côté joola qui
est un petit peu plus dur en ceci je
peux laisser c'est là où vous voyez vous
montrer celle ci alors cela devait déjà
passé c'est lent et les genres pas si
elle est totalement sèche elle est un
échange riche miel vedobe et vous
faites-vous la seconde eh ben pour
dessécher la ville où des c5 qui se
nomme la bigoudène avons envoyé oui oui
et ça c'est le sommet de la foi et vinci
c'est ça qui tient la coiffe tout ça
quand je dessèche les coiffes je mets
tout mon temps de sécher une au but
comme ça dépend des coiffes que j'ai si
c'est une demi journée et le lendemain
je l' ai fini alors je mets moins
longtemps moins loin
vous voyez j'ai fini et c'est lent cela
vous lever que vous aviez commencé hier
lorsque l on l ait commencé hier ça ils
font ce très long c'est très long ce
serait long bien sûr non la coiffure
elle est entièrement faux plate forme
est là et vous hisser là est fini
elle est finie il ya plus maintenant
qu'elle a même que la mecque sur la tête
sur la tête avec le petit bonnet les
gays et puis les lacets ce sans pouvoir
les nacelles ici j'ai l'impression que
la cei sont beaucoup plus souples que la
coiffe ce n'est pas du tout l'âme à la
même manière de repasser c'est moi à me
donner ces moyens ni d'eau ni c'était
par l'ami donc cru ça parce qu'il ya un
tout petit peu d'amis dont on était
beaucoup moins parce que le lhc doit
flotter un peu au vent eh ben vous voyez
louis sa flotte
j'avais un petit veille
on
où